we spent some time and I gave you guys
security and trust issues by proving
that the derivatives for these functions
are actually results - not that hard to
learn and it tells some very useful
things
so let's rehearse them very quickly the
derivative side is the derivative of cos
is negative sine the derivative of tan
is okay excellent now therefore it
follows directly on from that that if
you know the dream it is that tells you
about the integrals right from one you
can conclude the other okay so for
instance from that first one what could
I write I could say since the derivative
of sine is cos if we go in Reverse the
integral of cos with respect we ought to
expect to be sine now by the way I have
written an indefinite integral sir plus
my constant okay good now I could do the
same kind of thing here and I could say
well therefore the integral of negative
sine is but you know it makes more sense
that we'd be expecting positive siding
yeah but you can't just get rid of that
negative so what is that going to mean
for the indefinite integral it'll be
negative cos join it and when you go in
the other way than other direction when
you're differentiate this you get your
negative sign and the negatives will
cancel great one last one
the integral of SEC squared is equal to
10 plus a constant okay so nothing too
dramatic right now these are your basic
results can I just warn you right
because you're learning these at the
same time like most people now that you
have both of these it is sorry so easy
to confuse the two okay you're like but
the opposite processes yeah I know
that's kind of exactly why it happens
worse with tree uhm worst with tree
so because they flip back and forth so
it's very easy to for instance read oh
yeah the integral of sine gives you
cause because you think you have
differentiated right but it's negative
cause because of your come from here
really so please be careful particularly
these first few steps when you're doing
your integration and it's needed all
that kind of thing
pay lots of attention to whether you're
differentiating or integrating double
check out as you write it okay